but who do you think that that sounds
like oh Which chapter is that from I'm
getting a little Deja Vu wibes from you
probably heard it you probably heard it
which chapter is that I I'll say it's 53
name I'll I'll give you the name in a
second I promise you I'll give you name
bro no not yet not yet ain't going to be
slick with me
dog it's
God it's
God it's God well I'm a Christian myself
so um I look into Islam I I even read
the Quran so um big thing for me is G
the difference of Jesus obviously that
is a big thing we we're monotheist we
believe in God we believe in the
prophets but it's about what we believe
about the prophets that I see is like a
fundamental like difference there you
know so um and what the what the Quran
says about the Bible that's like what it
talks about the previous scriptures that
right there when I was reading the Quran
and I saw what it said about like the
Torah the inil and stuff like that that
honestly fascinated me but what so what
is your guys's view on what the Quran
says about the Bible yeah I think the
Christianity and Islamic text in general
even the old ones sh a lot of
correlation if you like the Book of
Genesis chapters in Genesis especially
37 to I believe 39 the story of Joseph
you he's a young kid gets betrayed by
his brothers and then through his
character and his resilience he rises to
a position of authority and even in that
chapter uh I believe Joseph talks about
God and His deeper connection with God
his ability to interpret dreams we have
that same inah YF as well but there's
just different correlations where the
Quran explicitly mentions Allah as the
one and only God but in Christianity
there's just God so there's that
monotheism but who is the figure of
worship right so it's just some
different correlations and I think it's
really interesting I've looked into
Christianity a little bit and I
definitely there's there's a lot of
correlation yeah yeah I mean yeah the uh
Abraham his sons the tribes of Israel I
mean like chapter 2 is heavy on the
story of Moses and Israel and stuff like
that right in the Quran Surah Bak so yes
it's a lot of there's a there's a
connect there right um I think so when
it comes to who God is and like um
that's the question that's the question
you know yeah and that's like and I
think uh people try to like logically
Define it but you know there's a lot of
strong faith when it comes to
Christianity I've visited churches and
there's many people who are very very
faithful towards Christianity
but there's people who are very very
faithful towards Islam that question can
be answered through faith and Faith only
I think you can't define something
that's supposed to be Faithfully
believed in through logic right so
that's one of yeah it it'll have a limit
you can talk about it logically but if
you're talking about God there's a yeah
there's a going to be a road block where
yeah that takes over definitely so so
what in when in my conversations with
some of my Muslim friends they have told
like it's a constant thing that I hear
like uh we believe in the Bible or the
Torah and Angel and in the scriptures um
as they were originally in their form
right that they believe that they have
been tampered with and stuff like that
do you guys hold the same view about
that about the scriptures being
corrupted not in their like we we they
they tell me I don't have the original
gospel and stuff like
that um and in terms of Christianity
alone well not not just alone like so
like if say oh look like the the Quran
says that I have to believe in the in
the gospel right I have to follow it and
they'll say yes but that's the original
gospel you don't have you don't have
where do they where do they get that
information from they it's just
something they say like you know you so
for that you have to really track back
all the old texts and all this and I
mean if you say that do you have the
evidence to back that up that the Bible
even the Mini Bible that you're holding
in your hand is corrupt or it's
incorrect you know so you have to have
that evidence same thing correlates with
even Quran even with same thing dude I
like you that's what I say that's
absolutely I say okay if it's once again
I think the underlying Foundation being
the faith itself yeah you know okay for
sure so so then so then you don't
believe that like the the scriptures
were like corrupted in any way you you
believe that it's it's still I I need
the evidence either that proves it or
does not prove it that's how it is if
you look at it from an academic point of
view or from a historian's point of view
cuz this is history absolutely so you
have to consider the evidence
something that sort of implies that
somewhere down the line the text was yes
exactly like I said I like you a lot
that's that's different usually a
different response than I usually get
but I I appreciate that cuz that's an
honest approach you know like what's
what's what's the evidence that you have
to say this on either side I love it so
then so then about Jesus then okay so if
according to the Quran I have to follow
the gospel right I have to believe in
all the scriptures even Muhammad as a as
a as a prophet that came after him right
they're all supposed to be one message
they're all supposed to be in line with
each other but obviously there's core
differences when I read the gospel and I
read about Jesus I see that you know he
was crucified and rose again on the
third day I see that he's the son of God
who you know Saves the World from their
sins right and Islam and the Quran has a
different narrative when it comes to
Jesus that he wasn't crucified
pretending on you know pertaining to
that verse um that he's not the Son of
God that's straight up no way you know
how do do I or how do we reconcile that
then the once again the fundamental
principle with Christianity is if you're
a Christian and you say that I don't
believe that Jesus is a Son of God
you're not considered Christian right
right and if I as a Muslim believe that
oh Jesus is a Son of God and I myself am
directly opposing to the Islamic
principles same thing with the
Christianity principles you know and the
big thing is that believing in the
Oneness of God Allah and Prophet
Muhammad sahu alaihi wasallam being the
final Prophet you know that that's
actually one of the things that you have
to consider in the shahada when you're
converting to Islam so it's it's once
again one of those things as a Christian
you have to have firm Faith the fact
that Jesus is indeed the Son of God yeah
but when you look at it from an Islamic
point of view you have to believe that
Allah is the one and only God the
prophet Muhammad is the final Prophet
God does not have any sons right right
right so so how like let's say again
pertains back to the core differences
that we have yeah that's what I'm saying
and so I'm I'm like so this is this is
obviously as a Christian this would be
what I would say for me was a problem
when I was reading the Quran obvious
right and so and for a Muslim it would
be a problem for for them absolutely my
my thing is is like um it's when the
Quran says that I have to believe in the
gospel right and I have to like I I
don't stand on nothing if I don't stand
on the scriptures that was revealed and
stuff like that so if I do that like I
think it's chap 5:47 it says let the
people of the Gospel will judge by what
Allah has revealed in it you know it's
one of my favorite verses so I like yeah
that's right if I judge by the gospel
the gospel says Jesus died for
crucifixion that he's the son of God
then that would mean that for me
anything outside of that is objectively
false right so how as a
Muslim
how yeah I'm sorry so how as a
Muslim do you do you Recon like is there
a Reconciliation for that CU for me that
would mean that Islam is like Islam is
making a mistake by saying that the
gospel is true cuz it like kind of works
against itself in my eyes do do you know
that if they mean by the biblical
version of it like it's they're
completely referring to the Bible itself
or is it another Islamic text that is
ref it's referring to to the to the
gospel you know like so historically the
gospel has always been what you know the
church has used for 2,000 years right
you know the the new test like we don't
have anything else other than that we've
had little things try to come up that
has been like you know seen as forgeries
and stuff that aspect once again is like
the evidence right so there people
coming up to you saying oh the gospel
might be corrupted and then you could
come up and say give me evidence and I
have to come up and say okay so where is
the evidence that this is the exact
biblical gospel that the Quran is
talking about if you could provide the
evidence for that because in Islam if
you believe anything apart from Allah
being your God and Prophet Muhammad
being the final prophet of Allah if you
believe in anything apart from that
there there's going to be another
Prophet or there might be another sole
Divine figure like somebody else apart
from Allah that deserves the same amount
of worship yeah you are going against
the very fundamental core of Islam in
theory you will not be considered Muslim
right right same thing as uh same thing
once again in Christianity if I were to
come up and say oh there's this text
that suggests that you know Jesus might
not be the son Son of God or there might
be another son then uh I'm going against
the core values of Christianity itself
you know and then once again that
argument is stitched back to the faith
aspect of it right there's something
within you that makes you believe in
Christianity you just know there's a God
and Jesus is the son of God same thing
with me that I know there's Allah and
Prophet Muhammad is the final Prophet
for for so for me it's not so much like
uh like the faith for I I believe that
there's evidences that that Jesus
brought and came with that that proved
that he was who he said he was right
that like I believe in the historic like
the the crucifixion was a historical
event um the empty tomb historical event
right and um you know the apostles going
around saying we saw him he's alive and
them dying for what they believe they
saw you know and then um the emergence
of the church after that and stuff like
that so I you know I have my reasons
that of why I put my faith in
yes exactly exactly and so now because
of that when I'm looking into the Quran
and I'm looking at what it says about
Jesus and I see that obviously it it it
has core differences and objections to
what I believe you know goes to the
historical Jesus for me like that's like
I'm I have to make a judgment at this
point you know and faithful judgment
yeah well not just a faithful Jud it's
like it's based off the off the
evidences that I'm Ling
Christianity yes yes so Christianity and
Islam so weighing weighing it both out
and I have to I have to make that
judgment and So based off the Judgment
I'm like this in Islam seems
inconsistent with like the historicity
of Jesus and like even within itself
like if when when you ask like for
example are you are you sure that it's
talking about like the biblical gospel
or the you know is there some Islamic
text that is referring to which was an
excellent question when I look into
Islamic sources like um like the the
life of the Prophet have you read that
by IB Hasam oh okay well I'll show you
that really quick there's a it's the
earliest biography of Muhammad that we
have and on page 103 and 104 you have uh
this narrative where Muhammad is
basically sending out his companions to
spread the message of Islam and he and
he does it he says just like Jesus did
when he sent out his disciples and he
names him as you know Matthew names him
even Paul he names him and names John
and says that John wrote the Gospel as
Jesus dictated it and so like this is
even in an Islamic Source I'm like whoa
so they even they even early Islam
acknowledges the gospel that I have you
know like this whole there's a different
gospel or something like it's kind of a
newer type of like thought process is
what I'm saying so like if that is the
case that the gospel I have is
definitely the gospel that the Quran is
talking about then I believe Islam has
an internal problem you know
cuz if if the gospel that I have is true
then that would mean that the Quran is
false because it goes against the gospel
you get what I'm
saying I think I think you bring up a
good point and uh you say that the
evidence that you received from uh that
you read about Jesus Christ the evidence
that you Reed leads you to believe that
the Quran has
inconsistencies when it comes to I could
say the same thing about what I've read
about Prophet Muhammad and what I've
read about the qu that uh the Bible has
aspects that do not exactly correlate
with the history that seems to be true
and uh I think you bring up excellent
points about the gospel this and that
but um I do believe that fundamentally
if you were to go and say that you know
Jesus is not the Son of God you would no
matter the evidence I bring up I would
not be considered Christian because I'm
denying the very the very first aspect
that you need to be a Christian yeah so
if I were to come and say that Quran has
inconsistencies or there's anything
apart from Prophet Muhammad not being
the final Prophet or God having a son or
anyone else apart from Allah being
worthy of worship I'm going against the
Quan itself when it comes to that so you
have to consider those two aspects I I
definitely do so so so the area that I
would like to go to basically is why I
would ask you why why do you believe
that actually can I give you why I
believe uh absolutely yeah I I'll go my
I'll do mes first before I like try to
ask excuse go
so I believe that an important thing and
this is one thing I noticed that Muslims
cherish is continuity like the the the
constant thing that I hear with Islam is
that you know the all the prophets had
the same message and they they presented
the same Theology and the same God one
God one worthy of worship he sends the
prophets obey him submit to him and
stuff like that right and that is
something I fundamentally agree with
that there's Contin it and that was
actually one of the things that like in
the Bible how you tell if someone is a
false prophet is if they're not in line
with what God has has revealed if they
come out and they say hey I'm a prophet
but they're contradicting what the
prophet said then they're not a prophet
you can X them out you know so
continuity for me is important and so
the reason why I believe what I believe
about Jesus is like I see the prophets
teaching the same thing like for example
about the Messiah and the prophecies
about the m side what he will do what he
will be like and things of this and
things of this nature so there's one
thing I want to show you that's one of
my favorite verses in the Bible is that
okay okay and I want I want your
thoughts by the way have you you said
you looked into you looked into
Christianity a little bit before
Christian text I haven't necessarily
fully read the Bible okay okay for sure
for sure so this might be fresh for
you at least this this chapter so this
is um
well I I I'll read it and you and I want
you to tell me who you think it sounds
like okay absolutely okay so and then
I'll give you all the information where
I'm reading from so it says he was
despised and rejected by Men A Man of
Sorrows and acquainted with grief and as
one who from men hide their faces he was
despised and we esteemed him not surely
he has borne our griefs and carried our
sorrows yet we esteemed him stricken
Smitten by God and Afflicted upon Him U
I'm sorry but he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed for our
iniquities and upon him was the
punishment that brought us peace and
with his wounds we are healed all we
like sheep have gone astray we have
turned everyone to his own way and the
lord has laid on him the sins of us all
so like if I were to ask you like who
does that just sound like chap is that I
I'll tell you in just a second I promise
but it's like isah Isaiah Isaiah Isaiah
53 it's it's a very good quote um yeah
it's it's very good it does share some
correlations yeah that's all I have to
say so if you were if you were to guess
like off of the sound of this right off
reading this what who do you think it
fits think who do you think this I I I'm
asking you I'll give I I promise you
I'll give my
opinion it's a it's a good question you
know and
uh obviously in both quranic and
biblical text when you when you take
some quotes uh you can interpret as a if
you if you if you read the chronics
verses as a Christian you would think
that oh this shares correlations with
Christ but if I were to read it I'd say
oh this shares correlations with
Muhammad do you believe that but they
don't necess but they don't necessarily
have to pertain to each other you know
it's like I as a Muslim coming from
purely Muslim background could read a
quote entirely from the Bible and think
hm this shares some correlations with
the prophet and you as a Christian could
read a quote from the Quran or Worse
from the this shares correlations with
Bible's interpretation of Christ Bible's
interpretation of Jesus you know what I
mean so so I I think that going Beyond
like personal interpretation I think
that we can what would be your take on
it I gave you mind yeah so like I think
like I think that there is a I think
like there's a clear description and
like there's a laid out description of
what this person is or what he does or
what happens to him that we can like
narrow it down you know uh like so it
says for he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed and
punished for our iniquities and it says
that the lord has laid on him the sins
of us all you know we can we can C like
obviously we don't believe you don't
believe that muham God put our sins on
Muhammad or that he was pierced for our
sins or transgressions that he took our
punishment you know there's only one
person that that fits that that that
narrative right and that's that's Jesus
Jesus died exactly so like even if like
you know without being a Christian or a
Muslim you hear that and you know the
story like you know the narrative like
you know you're if you're in the U you
know the story of Jesus even if you
don't believe in it and you're you read
this you're like oh yeah that's talking
about Jesus you know and um so that's
that's what I'm saying like it has
particular description
that like is clear as day yeah it's
talking about Jesus you know and so it's
it's stuff like this so this is Isaiah
53 this was written 700 years before
Jesus so your point being if you were to
go up to anyone even someone who's an
atheist and read this story here
Berkeley uh they would kind of know that
it's Jesus so I could say if I went to
uh Saudi Arabia and said something about
that pertains to Prophet Muhammad they
would immediately know yes so I think we
have to consider the location that we're
in too you're true so so this this this
is my thing like you're right like it's
uh what do what do people culturally
know or based on their knowledge right
and so I think that with even with
Muslims they they have a general
understanding all over the world of the
story the Christian story of Jesus or
Jesus is is also a character in exactly
a huge one you can't say the same about
Muhammad about about what is Muhammad
mentioned in the bible or no yeah no
yeah yeah of course that aspect too so
when the people who read the Quran they
learn about Jesus they want to look into
it a little bit more say Okay I want to
see the correlations I want to see the
variations what are the differences what
are not the differences I agree with
this I do not agree with that you know
but the Bible has no mention of the
Prophet Muhammad so it does not really
give uh people who identify with
Christianity an incentive to look into
the Quran a little bit more you know
very true that's very true a fundamental
point but OB it pertains to each exact
individual because a lot of people who
are Christian they are well aware of the
fact that the Quran and the Bible have
correlations as well as variations so it
gives them an opportunity for them to
look at the differences yes absolutely
yeah that's a great Point that's
actually something with me like I would
not have I probably would not have like
for example I know more about Islam way
more than I do about Hinduism because
Hinduism doesn't mention Christianity or
anything like that you know when I found
out that Islam has stuff to say about
Jesus and our prophets like we have we
have that like common ground that we can
talk about that's what made me look into
it you know so what you said is
absolutely correct like Christians
wouldn't have an incentive to dive into
Islam if they don't know that it's
talking but but Muslims have an
incentive to dive into the previous
scriptures and stuff like that cuz it
talks about the you know the people of
the book when you're growing up you just
hear things about you know thean the
same because if you were raising I
assume a Christian background yes yeah
yeah and I was raised in a Muslim
background we hear that correlation you
know from pastors Maybe from imams you
know we hear that that there's some some
similarities and some differences so one
of those things okay so nice nice so
okay so that's Isaiah 53 there's another
one I wanted to show you just really
quick so cuz remember I was saying for
me it's about continuity right so this
is now I'm going to go to the Psalms
this is the zabor the zabor the Psalms
of David and
so this is what what he says in the
Psalms
about the Messiah he says start at verse
14 here now Psalm 22 like it's not long
but it's it's really good if you have a
chance he says I am poured out like
water and all my bones are out of
joint um my heart is like Wax it is
melted within my breast my strength is
dried up like a post and my tongue
sticks to my jaws you lay me in the dust
of death for dogs Encompass me a company
of evildoers encircles me they have
pierced my hands and my
feet I can count all my bones they stare
and gloat over me they divide my
garments among them and cast clothing
for my Lots all so stuff like that right
we this uh is talking about the
crucifixion yes yes sir yes sir matter
of fact and you have to believe this in
order to be a Christian if you reject
this idea you're not Christian yeah
correct yeah it's a core thing but um so
what what I'm saying is is like we're
looking at I'm looking at
how the prophets or the previous
scriptures that came before The Gospel
that I have how they talked about the
Messiah and what will happen to him
right Psalms David is writing this a
thousand years before Jesus is born
Isaiah the one that showed you the first
time that's 700 years before Jesus is
born and so we're seeing this constant
thread that the Messiah is going to
suffer the Messiah is going to be the
rede the the atonement sacrifice he God
is going to put our sins on him then
he'll return uhhuh and then he'll return
so you have this this continuity with
the prophets that's that's sharing this
now there just for the sake of time
there's a few more but I don't want to
like you know bombard you or anything
like that okay but like there's a few
more that talk about how the Messiah
like in Zechariah 12:10 if you you might
forget this but in Zechariah 12:10 it
says that he like the people when he
comes back the Jews will see the one
whom they pierced and they will mourn
and cry they will feel sorry for what
they did yeah so that's that's another
reference you know and um so you have
these things that talk about the Messiah
suffering and going through this and
then we have the gospel that where Jesus
pops up and says yeah this is me this is
about me I fulfilled this so that's why
I believe it like it's a continuity and
so the problem I have with with Muhammad
per se is that obviously Muhammad goes
against that he's like no Jesus didn't
suffer he didn't go through that he's
not the atonement for the sins does not
mention that and obviously there's
different aspects that you have to
believe in but yeah the Quran there's no
mention of Jesus suffering in or being
crucified that's one of the fundamental
aspects that comes with Christianity
know and even if you look at the story
of Joseph per se there's very very key
differences you know in Islam I'm not
sure how it is in Genesis my memory is a
little foggy on it but in Sur YF uh
Yousef Joseph gets thrown in the well by
his brothers it might be a little bit
different yeah it was it was a ditch but
same thing it's it's some different
correlations and if I were to say the
very very most common thing that is
repeated
in there's only one God Allah and
Prophet Muhammad is SL Prophet if I were
to say anything apart from that if I
were to reject the idea of crucification
that Jesus that suffered for our sins I
would not be considered Christian if I
was chrisan but if I were to say that uh
if I were to reject
Muhammed the very first thing that comes
with Islam I would not be considered
Muslim do you would you be able to cuz
you said it doesn't like really touch on
Jesus suffering or anything like that
could you be a Christ I mean a Muslim
and and do and still believe that Jesus
was crucified maybe not have the same
theological things like oh he was
crucified for my sins and stuff like
that but can you believe Jesus was
crucified and still be a Muslim you know
uh it's a if if I were to believe fully
completely believe in the biblical
interpretations that means I'm believing
that Jesus is also see if I believe in
that then I have to believe that Jesus
is the son of God and that Jesus will
return and the fact that um Jesus died
for our sins okay we have to believe
that so at that point I'm fully
Christian right because if I if I
believe in one thing and if I don't
believe in another then I'm rejecting
the idea of religion as a whole not even
Christianity or Islam right uh if I were
to say that oh well I believe that
there's only one God Allah but Prophet
Muhammad isn't the final Prophet there's
going to be another prophet come later
on yeah you know or the prophet will be
revealed later on then I'm not Muslim
yeah so you have to like really fully
believe in it we all the way as you're
in all the way about Christianity I'm
all so let's say you have those
foundational beliefs about Islam there's
one God Muhammad is his last prophet and
stuff like that you believe in all the
prophets um but but you also believe
that Jesus was crucified not that he's
the son of God not that any of this but
you do believe that he was crucified
well that's like an individual thing
isn't it if I if I believe that Jesus
was crucified then I I have to believe
that Jesus was a Son of God and I have
to follow the biblical interpretation
because there's no quranic
interpretations of Jesus actually being
crucified there's there's there's
something that it says uh it says like
talking about the Jews boasting it says
that they boast and that we've killed
the Messiah and so Allah responds and
says um they they talking about the Jews
they they neither they neither killed
him nor crucified him but it was made to
appear so to them um but rather we um
but we took them up to raised them up to
to ourselves that's that's what that's
415 an alter State you didn't exactly
die went into occultation that you come
back later
on well yes yeah there's well there's
there's interpretation that like um cuz
there's a verse that says that um it's
the word is mut in the Arabic which
means to take the soul or cause to die
um and so like it happens even when you
sleep like it says Allah takes the soul
when you sleep um some people say that
that's like a a temporary death or like
a cousin or brother of death or
something like that but but so yeah so
Allah says in chapter 3: 55 I believe it
is that you know remember Jesus when I
uh you know mut a will take your soul or
cause you to die so there's like a
little kind of gray area there where
whether Jesus died or not specifically
in that that quote that you show me was
it the Psalms Psalms and there's a very
very exact representation for Jesus
nails like Wax bre like it gives you a
representation of Jesus being crucified
that isn't exactly mentioned in the
Quran you do bring up some points about
you know it's implied but the Quran
never explicitly directly States some
things apart from a select that really
implies towards something just like the
Bible apart from like crucification and
that Jesus is the son of God that Jesus
will return you have to believe those
things to be to a Christian right
and the Quran doesn't exactly mention
you know so if I were to believe in
Jesus being crucified from how it is
mentioned in the Psalms then I'm
rejecting what was going on in the Quran
you because it's one or the other right
yes and I can say oh I believe this but
then I don't believe that and if I as a
Christian come up to you and say I
believe in the crucification but I don't
believe that Jesus is the son of God you
know I have to believe that so if I were
to come up and say that you know I
believe in the quranic interpretation of
Jesus but I don't believe that Prophet
Muhammad is a final Prophet I won't be
considered Muslim so you have to believe
those things you know that's so so what
are your thoughts then on how you doing
brother what so what are your thoughts
on like the so the the the thread that I
was I was drawing with the continuity of
the of the prophets do you think that
that holds weight to the truth of a
matter uh whether something is like true
or happens if it's like consistent what
what what are your thoughts on that cuz
for me like I said like that's a main
thing is the consistency of the message
of the prophets if they're consistently
saying the Messiah is going to die the
Messiah is going to be crucified the
Messiah is going to take our sins isn't
that what we should believe if we
believe the prophets yeah well same
thing can be said with like the
revelations in the Quran you know the
prophet kept giving Revelations and
there's that consistency you can find in
the Quran too recurring messages
recurring themes recurring aspects and
the Quran also has consistency and yeah
you could say like consistency is an
aspect to authenticity but it's one of
the aspect it's not one of the so so
you're talking when you say in the Quran
it has consistency itself that would be
the Quran itself with what it talks
about saying that it's consistent about
what it talks about right but not what
I'm saying is that cuz he never directly
says it you have to read it and it like
gives very very heavy implication that
it is cons the Bible never exactly says
believe in the Bible and the Bible only
right
yeah so yeah that's not what I'm saying
what I'm saying is like so in the Quran
you're saying in the Quran it
demonstrates or shows that it's
consistent within within itself right I
understand what you're saying my so my
thing is that but that's that's just the
Quran if the Quran has internal
consistency what I'm saying is not just
like for example if I was just going off
the gospel right I can say that the
gospel is internally consistent but at
the same time the gospel if the gospel
contradicted the psalm you know or the
prophets it's not it may be internally
consistent but it's not consistent with
what came before it like it's
contradicting those things so like the
Quran can have internal consistency but
my my thing is that it's not consistent
with what came before it how so can you
provide an example so like like yeah for
what I'm saying like so Jesus being the
Son of God who is crucified that is a
consistent we see it in the Psalms we
see it in the prophet Isa Isaiah Prophet
Zechariah uh even Daniel we see we see
it in the prophets and then we also see
it in the gospel Jesus is the son of God
that Jesus is the son of God and that
Jesus is
crucified so right now of of course in
the um in the Quran it rejects that
Jesus is the son of God um and is and it
is consistent about that it's consistent
Jesus is not the Son of God so that's an
internal consistency there is no Son of
God not just Jesus there right right
there is no Son of God at all right so
it's consistent yeah it's consistent
that there that you know
right it's consistent on that but that
concept that goes against what the
previous scriptures say it's not
consistent with Islamic and quranic
scriptures yeah the gospel they say that
the that Jesus is the son of godm so
like the P like for example the psalm
says the Messiah is the Son of God um
Prophet Prophet Daniel say that you know
the Messiah is the Son of God um uh the
gospel obviously says that Jesus is the
son of God he says himself like I am the
Son of God you know you know my father
sent me you know all that kind of stuff
so you have these scriptures that the
Quran points to like it says I it came
confirming these scriptures it's in line
with them but at the same time it's not
consistent with them see Quran is
consistent with with the Oneness of God
Allah being the one and only God and
then it's also consistent with saying
that Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is the final Prophet yeah so
when we come to that and all the
prophets that came before him have the
same deep connection with God and they
preach the same message so there's
consistency with prophets as well with
prophecy as well and the holy B you know
it's just what it's being consistent
towards when it comes to Christianity
and Islam there's different aspects to
it so if there's any inconsistency
especially like on core doctrines
wouldn't that be alarming like if if if
there like G God having a son is a core
thing that's like like that's no as as a
Muslim no you don't believe that a a
prophet of Allah would ever teach that
he has a son cuz you you believe that
that goes against his Oneness so if a
prophet is teaching that then he would
be in Islam that would be a false
prophet that would be a he'll be a liar
right if he's trying to say I'm a
prophet of God while at the same time
teaching that God has a son so that's a
core thing that if if there's a
difference on that then we have to weigh
out who is consistent if the prophets
consistently teach that God has a son
and then Muhammed comes and teaches no
God doesn't have a son that's a problem
you know cuz he's not in line with what
the prophets taught that's that's my
position is like that continuity on
something as core as that is it it's a
make or break you know but the prophets
you referring to are the Christian
interpretations of the not not it's not
Christian interpret ation it's like
these are who this is who they are you
know this when we go to their books you
know when I go to the book of Isaiah
that like he wasn't a Christian you know
um it's not my interpretation of him I
go to the book of Isaiah I read what he
says you know I go to the Psalms I read
what David said I go to the Torah I read
what Moses said you know they they
weren't Christians but they had they we
can see their theology we can see their
revelation we can see what they taught
you know what I'm saying and these are
all things that that Moses
points to that or I'm sorry that
Muhammad points to like I am confirming
these scriptures and these prophets so
if he's out of if he's confirming these
prophets and at the same time
contradicting them that for me is a is a
big problem he's confirming the idea
that God has a son is he explicit I
don't think he's doing that no so so
like that's that's the problem that's
for me this is where I believe it's the
Dilemma is that he's he says that he
confirms what the prophet said and and
scriptures but within his Revelation
does the prophet Muhammad himself preach
you know yeah yeah muham so Muhammad
himself preaches that Allah is
absolutely singular and he doesn't have
a son far be it from him he's way above
that that's not the only thing that's
one of the things but that's not the
only thing yeah yeah there's a lot of
things we can talk about but yeah I'm
trying to just focus on certain you know
the core thing right uh but yeah you're
right but so just that core fundamental
message like that is a that's a big
thing that's a huge thing that's a
you're in the you're in the truth of of
of uh the religion or you're not you
know even Allah says like people who say
that the Messiah is the Son of God they
are imitating disbelievers of old and
Allah's curse be upon them because
they're ignorant you know that's chapter
9:30 like Allah is serious when it comes
to him having a son that he doesn't play
about that that's what I know from the
Quran and so when the prophets are
teaching that he does that God does have
a son that is it's a make a break either
all these different prophets were
actually really dis
disbelievers um and then that that would
be like still a problem with Muhammad
cuz he's saying that these prophets are
true it just it just doesn't work
oh